[Music]
do you know how to identify some of the
most dangerous commonly known creatures
and when to immediately ask for help
after being bitten from caterpillars to
snakes these are some of the creatures
you should definitely stay away from
stay tuned to see a powerful snail that
can transmit up to 100 toxins with a
single bite if you're new here hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video and don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up now let's check out some of
the most dangerous creatures out there
pus caterpillar this is one of the
fluffiest caterpillars we have ever seen
isn't it completely adorable it's hard
to imagine that a fluff ball like this
could actually be dangerous right wrong
in 2014 and has been reported that young
children based from Florida to North
Carolina experienced traumatic pain
after coming in contact with one of
these fluffy creatures it might look
like a sleeping cat but the Puss
caterpillar actually comes with an
extremely toxic spine hidden in the fur
coat if you happen to pet it you might
end up feeling pain that's similar to a
bee sting if you don't get help
immediately the pain can spread to all
areas of your body including your bones
and it usually lasts for 12 hours to
remove the spine it's recommended to use
a tape and pulling them off or visit a
hospital to get properly treated that is
if you actually notice it in the first
place it's been reported that the spines
are so small they aren't noticeable and
since the insect doesn't leave any bite
marks it's hard to figure out where the
pain is actually coming from the pain of
the steam can be so strong it was
compared to the pain of being burned or
on fire
lesson learned don't touch Buffy
creatures before identifying them and
making sure you won't end up in the
hospital hey guys the Arts
so excited to announce we're producing
our own original content head over to
the trendy for the best DIYs fashion
tips makeup hacks and so much more we
are sure you're going to love it and be
sure to let us know what you think in
the comment section
Indian red scorpion we all know that
seeing a scorpion is never good news but
you should be especially careful if you
spot the Indian red scorpion it's one of
the most dangerous species out there and
can be commonly found in India Pakistan
and Nepal it's orange red body it's
instantly recognizable and if you happen
to see it you really should run as fast
as you can to avoid any issues the
Scorpion is known to detect their prey
by sensing the vibrations in the air and
the earth through their sensory hairs
they mostly prey on insects and other
scorpions during the night and hide
during the day if you ever come in
contact with a red scorpion you should
run and get help as fast as you can if
not treated a red scorpion sting can be
fatal
they carry a complicated toxin that's
made of salts small molecules peptides
and proteins after entering the body the
toxin can quickly spread to your heart
and paralyze your lungs the bite also
has a negative effect on your muscles
especially those connected to the
central nervous system in some cases the
sting was fatal in less than 72 hours
will not treat it if you find yourself
in India Nepal or Pakistan be careful
when you wander around at night and keep
your eyes open for the Indian red
scorpion pufferfish if you've ever seen
Finding Nemo you might argue that
pufferfish are cute and we can't blame
you if you do if they're prepared
correctly you can actually eat them but
the truth of the matter is pufferfish
are actually one of the most dangerous
animals out there and they have been
crowned as the second most powerful
vertebrae on the planet you probably
know that a pufferfish escapes their
predators by ingesting huge amounts of
water which grows in their stomach and
allows them to quickly swim away but
they actually have a really strong
defense mechanism which comes in handy
especially when they get
by a fisherman if you're not careful
when you remove the hook from a puffer
fish you might end up getting stung the
toxin produced by these adorable fish is
so strong it paralyzes the diaphragm and
causes suffocation they also contain a
substance called tetrodotoxin which
makes them taste bad and is sometimes
even lethal to other fish it's been
reported that the substance is 1,200
times stronger than cyanide and if that
doesn't scare you it's also noted that
one puffer fish comes with enough toxins
to take on 30 full-grown adults so while
they look absolutely adorable and they
sometimes become an attractive prey to
the nearby predators puffer fish can and
will fight back when they since trouble
dart frog dart frogs are definitely
super cute and extremely colorful their
colors are instantly recognizable and
they might even catch us off guard it's
hard to imagine something this adorable
could be named one of the most toxic
species on earth right well it's true if
you happen to see a dart frog it's best
to run away as fast as you can these
colors might be appealing to humans but
it tells the Predators just how
dangerous they are you can find them in
rainforests of Central and South America
and they can easily be recognized by
their unique colors and patterns but
it's best to stay away as one golden
dart frog has enough toxins to face
20,000 mice at once we can't even
imagine the effect it might have on
humans
the frogs capture their prey with their
tongue and what's even more interesting
is that they actually end up eating a
lot of harmful insects in the process
however their nervous system is so
strong it's able to handle all extra
toxins and turn it into their own
advantage which is why their prey
doesn't bring out a fatal reaction
scientists are still studying these
frogs to understand how is such a tiny
creature able to react so well to toxic
substances in their bodies and look so
cute at the same time blue ringed
octopus
you probably noticed that the most
colorful creatures are usually the ones
that are the most dangerous the blue
ringed octopus looks totally awesome but
if you happen to come across one you
should stay away they can be seen in
tide pools in the Pacific Ocean
anywhere from Japan to Australia it's
only the size of a golf ball but we've
learned that size really doesn't matter
when it comes to powerful animals this
tiny creature carries a toxic substance
that's strong enough to face 26 adult
humans and in their lives within a
couple of minutes they're recognized as
one of the most dangerous animals out
there especially since their bites are
painless and might not look like they
can cause huge damage the truth is if
you do get bitten by the blue ringed
octopus its toxins immediately spread
through the rest of your body and cause
muscular weakness numbness and shortness
of breath which results in fatality
these underwater creatures also have an
impressive Anatomy and can be
practically invisible due to their
camouflaged look they're totally
flexible as a result of having a
completely boneless body they move
quickly and often lay sideways which is
why it's so easy to step on them in low
tide so be careful where you're stepping
and always be on the lookout for these
yellow and blue looking octopuses
catfish we all know catfish is someone
who pretends to be someone they're not
frequently used by the online world the
catfish are also an easily recognized
fish that come with whiskers that make
them look like actual cats they might be
one of the most commonly eaten species
but you should always pay attention to
how you're handling them when caught
they seem pretty harmless right well
it's true
they aren't really aggressive and most
people come in contact with the fish by
accident or during fishing but both salt
and freshwater catfish are actually
dangerous they come with three spines
and a stinging apparatus ready to fight
off any potential predators if you do
get stung by a catfish you will feel the
effects immediately the pain and
inflammation takes seconds to develop
and sometimes the pain can be so severe
it's lethal
if you do get stung by a catfish you
should immerse the affected area in hot
water to relieve the pain remove the
spines with tweezers and take
antibiotics to treat the infection
depending on the severity of the pain
it's recommended you ask for help and
visit a hospital to make sure the sting
doesn't require any medical attention
and can get treated normally while
catfish definitely aren't the most
dangerous species from our list they're
one of the most common ones just like in
the online world you never know what
you'll get when it comes to catfish
Eastern diamondback rattlesnake we bet
there's a few of you who can't even look
at online pictures of snakes without
getting shivers down your spine don't
worry this is the only snake i
mentioning in this video from anaconda
to Black Mamba snakes aren't exactly the
most pleasant creatures out there
rattlesnakes are fairly common and the
Eastern diamondback rattlesnakes can be
commonly found in North America and any
coastal scrub habitats from North
Carolina to Florida their name comes
from their diamond-like pattern they're
the largest snakes out there and
possibly the most dangerous out of all
rattlesnake species a rattlesnake often
strikes when it feels threatened
especially if it's captured while they
only attack in defense the diamondback
baby snakes are actually more dangerous
than adult as they have less control
over their aggression if you come across
this rattlesnake accidentally it's best
to stay away but if it strikes you
should absolutely ask for help their
bite includes a toxin that's harmful to
the human red blood cells and causes
tissue damage the pain is extremely
painful and at times the bite can be
fatal to humans luckily an antidote for
the diamondback rattlesnake bite is
widely available and treatment is
recommended so if you see a diamondback
rattlesnake shake itself you should
always run away before it manages to
strike black widow spider be honest do
you like spiders if you can handle
snakes we bet this next spider might
make you want to look away we can't
blame you spiders are scary but the
black widow has the reputation of being
one of these scariest spiders around
although it's as big as a paperclip it
can cause significant damage to its
preys its bite is reported to be 15
times stronger than the bite from a
rattlesnake when they strike they can be
fatal to small children and
cause muscle aches nausea and paralysis
of the diaphragm but despite the fact
these fighters are known to be the most
powerful they can rarely take on
full-grown adults what's perhaps most
unknown about the black widow bite is
that the effect of the bite is different
for everyone but very rarely will it end
up in fatalities
some people have experienced strong pain
while for others the bite was relatively
harmless the effect of the black widow
bite depends largely on the bitten area
if the toxin penetrates a callus the
effects will most likely be more
noticeable if you do see a black widow
you should never try to catch it as they
will only strike when they're attacked
but if you do get bitten by a black
widow make sure you treat the bite as
fast as possible fat-tailed scorpion
have you ever noticed that the least
popular animals seem to begin with the
letter S we can decide what's worse
snakes spiders or scorpions they're
definitely one of the least popular
animals out there but out of them all
it's the scorpions that are the most
dangerous they can be commonly found in
areas of Africa the Middle East and a
small part of Asia unlike the red Indian
scorpion the fat-tailed scorpion has a
unique tail that's visibly narrower and
instantly noticeable they're also larger
than any other species with a link
between 3.1 and 3.9 inches they hide
during the day and attack at night if
you get bitten by a fat tailed scorpion
the toxin in its bite will act very fast
and quickly spread to the rest of your
body the toxin will spread to the
central nervous system and cause
paralysis as well as respiratory failure
resulting in a fatality although you can
find these animals on some of the exotic
markets they're illegal in many parts of
the world because of its dangerous
reputation the law also states that if
the owner of this scorpion ends up
getting bitten they will not only have
to fight for their lives but they will
also face the authorities for everyone's
safety it's best to stay as far away
from these scorpions as possible cone
snail snails definitely don't have the
reputation of being a dangerous species
but you'll change your mind after
you hear about this type of snail can
you believe that cone snails carry more
than 100 different toxins in a single
harpoon like needle we're telling you
all dangerous animals start with the
letter S although they're not snails
you'd look twice at you should be
careful if you come in contact with
these powerful animals they got their
name by their cone-like shell which is
somewhat different from the usual round
shells we know these type of snails get
extremely aggressive if they're provoked
and aren't afraid to strike back to
fight off potential predators they use
their sharp poison loaded needles and
are totally transparent but strong
enough to penetrate a wetsuit the pain
isn't noticeable but the needles carry
up to 100 individual toxins which
instantly target different components of
the nervous system and can cause a
severe reaction you can find over 500
types of cone snails but one of the most
dangerous is known as the geography cone
the worst and probably the most ironic
part is there is no active treatment
available for the snails bite even
though it's been noted that some of the
tops ins usually have the potential of
being used for pharmaceutical purposes
who would have thought that a creature
so tiny could end up being so powerful
what's your favorite strange animal of
all time let us know in the comments for
more videos like this one check out five
famous logos reimagined as dangerous
weapons see you next time
[Music]